is it better this way all that way
it's horrible
ever way it's not very respect
with one's appearance mature reasonable
people are not supposed to go around
regretting the shape of their nose or
the way their hair falls yet you gaze in
the bathroom mirror and think why in my
brief existence on this planet does this
have to be me for those unhappy with
their looks
pictures are painful each view image
brings no bad news yet this isn't crazy
we care about our looks for a sound
reason because everyone judges us by
them because they determine the first
response to deal with the challenges of
our appearance we need to develop a
particular kind of wisdom here is a
start to learning how to cope with one's
looks
personal appearance simply is one of the
Lisa's Democratic paths of life it's a
lottery and you haven't won it's nothing
to do with you
nor is it to their credit that it is
them it just is
a bald man
appreciate your hair but no one else
will it's the ugly who had best place to
appreciate beauty
something the beautiful should bear in
mind when they're considering on whom to
bestow their favors people learn about
love from their parents and when they've
grown up often search for lovers who
remind them a little in some unconscious
way of mum or dad the good news is that
often mom or dad were quite weird or
ugly looking that helps to explain the
odd choices good-looking people
sometimes make thank God for ugly
parents the world is dominated by an
often unfair money hierarchy against
that it's refreshing that there's also
this strange looks hierarchy it doesn't
restore justice but if thumbs its nose
up at other sorts of injustice just a
little
however unfair the distribution of
appearance is today time will eventually
bring justice no one ends up happy with
how they look it's just a question of
waiting for some disenchantment may
start at 10 for others it may take
another 40 years but it will happen for
sure
rather than saying appearance doesn't
matter you can get better at noticing
the less obvious but still real beauty
in order places the trouble with our
culture isn't so much that we love
appearances but that we focus on to
narrow range of features and qualities
so start to get interested in someone's
August forehead note the melancholy
sweetness of their eyes admire an
expression of kindly acceptance point
out serenity a trusting face a candid
nose there are so many good and
attractive things we can see in people's
faces if we're alert to different types
of beauty and hopefully someone
somewhere will one day do the same for
us
you